donc le il ya deux choses qu'il faut
retenir quand on voit ça hein c'est que
globalement les émissions par personne
sont très au dessus et ça on va voir
plus tard de ce à quoi il faut pas
revenir pour que tout ça se termine
plutôt bien que mal mais par ailleurs
les choix techniques et les choix
d'infrastructures parce que c'est
essentiellement ça qui explique les
différences peuvent avoir déjà produit
des résultats extrêmement significatif
d'un pays à l'autre
alors la raison par exemple pour
laquelle la suisse a des émissions par
habitant très basse c'est
essentiellement le fruit de l'histoire
c'est très peu le fruit de considération
morale ou éthique à ce stade il se
trouve que la suisse l'organisation
s'est faite essentiellement en fond de
vallée
parce que de construire sur les flancs
de montagne c'est plus difficile donc on
est dans un contexte idéal pour faire
passer des trains qui vont pouvoir
desservir à peu près tout le monde
les trucs ne sont pas étalées en deux
dimensions ils sont étalés juste en une
dimension donc quand ça s'étale en une
dimension fait passer une voie de chemin
de fer le long de la dimension
et ça marche bien c'est également un
pays qui produit l'essentiel de son
électricité et sans émettre de co2
puisqu'ils ont un parc de production
électrique qui fait à peu près 50 50
entre le nucléaire et l'hydraulique
et enfin c'est un pays qui n'a pas
quelques industries particulièrement
émettrices de co2 il n'y a pas deux
hauts fourneaux
chez eux il n'y a pas de constructeur
automobile il n'ya pas d'aciéristes faut
que je vous ai dit et il n'y a pas de
raffinerie donc vous avez certaines
industries qui contribuent de manière
significative dans les émissions qui
n'existe pas chez eux
la france vous allez retrouver là aussi
pour partie pour une large partie le
choix du nucléaire
et puis vous allez retrouver aussi pour
partie pour tous les pays européens
versus les états unis le fruit de
l'histoire qui est que nos villes sont
apparus à une époque où l'attraction
autorisées n'étaient pas disponibles et
donc les déplacements sont plus courts
les logements sont plus facilement
collectif donc avec une baisse c'est ce
que je vous ai montré au premier cours
des émissions par mètre carré et c'est
donc il faut faire très attention quand
on juge les peuples à l'aune de ce
problème particulier et savoir bien
faire la différence entre la vraie
mauvaise volonté d'aujourd'hui
le fruit de l'histoire qui est ce qu'il
est encore une fois dans un certain
nombre de cas de figure on hérite
aujourd'hui davantage qu'on avait
absolument pas cherché si on regarde
maintenant à quoi ressemblent les
émissions par secteurs
alors là il s'agit d'un panorama mondial
voici d'où vient le co2 est parfois si
nos gars co2 un quart du co2 vient de ce
qu'on appelle les industries de
l'énergie qui en pratique recouvre les
centrales électriques et les raffineries
c'est essentiellement les centrales
électriques qui pèse dans cette affaire
donc un quart des émissions mondiales de
co2 c'est les centrales électriques et
dans ce car c'est essentiellement de
charbon qui va jouer son rôle toujours
un quart en ordre de grandeur enfin
entre cinquième et un quart vient de la
déforestation
un quart en ordre de grandeur vient de
ce qu'on appelle les procédés
industriels donc c'est tout ce qui n'est
pas électrique
enfin électricité plus exactement et
raffinage dans l'industrie
donc c'est toutes les sources de chaleur
qu'on va avoir quand on va avoir besoin
pour faire de l'acier du verre du
plastique etc et les sources de chaleur
dont on va avoir besoin pour transformer
les matières ainsi obtenu en produits
manufacturés
retenez que dans les émissions de
l'industrie à peu près 80% vient de ce
qu'on appelle de l'industrie de base
c'est-à-dire les industries qui vont
fabriquer les matériaux de base des
produits chimiques de base les métaux
les plastiques et ses transformations
ambulants 12 derrière c'est quelque
chose qui est mec considérablement moins
que d'avoir fabriquer l'acier au début
du processus
le chauffage des bâtiments représente à
peu près 10%
c'est en moyenne mondiale puisque
évidemment mais pas de pays ont souv pas
et enfin le transport maritime terrestre
et aérien représente de l'ordre de 17%
des émissions de co2 dans ce paquet le
transport routier est stricto sensu et
aux alentours de 12 12 à 13 et vous avez
3 à 4 pour le maritime et environ 2 à 3
pour l'aérien après vous pouvez regarder
les émissions de méthane
alors les émissions de méthane elle
deux gros de grosses ressources c'est
d'une part l'exploitation des
hydrocarbures
l'exploitation des hydrocarbures comme
je voulais dit lors du cours précédent
vous avez deux sources la première c'est
le méthane qui est dissout dans l'huile
extraits quand on remonte du pétrole le
méthane qui est contenu dans les
gisements de charbon et qui s'est formée
au moment où le gisement lui même s'est
formée et les mineurs réclament en
général qu on ventile des mines et on
peut pas vraiment leur en vouloir pour
ça et enfin vous avez les fuites dans le
système d'extraction et de transport de
gaz naturel
donc tout ça ça vous fait des émissions
de méthane c'est la partie énergie
après vous avez une deuxième source qui
est agricole et en particulier tous les
processus de fermentation anaérobie
c'est à dire dès que vous avez de la vie
quelque part qui se déroule en l'absence
d'oxygène alors en général le
métabolisme des bactéries concernés cd m
du méthane donc la fermentation dans les
tas de fumier la fermentation dans
l'estomac des vaches la fermentation au
fond des marécages
tout ça ça fait du méthane et les
sources humaines dominante c'est la
riziculture parce que vous avez de la
fermentation anaérobie sous la couche
d'eau de la rivière
les vaches vous avez à peu près un
milliard et demi de bovins à la surface
de la planète dont la biomasse est
supérieure à celle des hommes et qui
contribue également de manière très
significative aux émissions de méthane
et après vous avez des petits trucs qui
sont plus secondaires les déchets ce qui
en fait l'aval de la chaîne alimentaire
donc c'est les épluchures de patates
qu'on a mise dans un trou et qui
fermente correspondent à 20% des
émissions de méthane est ici vous avez
une petite partie des émissions qui
correspond à la combustion incomplète
lors des incendies le protoxyde d'azoté
est un gaz comme j'avais mis des
commentaires je suis désolé je les avais
oubliés
le protoxyde d azote est quelque chose
qui est pour l'essentiel liée aux
engrais azotés quand vous mettez des
engrais azotés
sur le sol pour faire pour la
fertilisation azotée et culture et bien
une petite partie des nitrates que vous
avez dans les molécules épandu va subir
une réduction avec l'oxygène de l'air et
ça va conduire à l'apparition d'un gaz
qui s'appelle le protoxyde d'azoté qui
est un gaz à effet de serre les
halocarbures dont je vous ai parlé ont
débuté avec une famille qui portait le
doubs sigle de cfc chlorofluorocarbures
il s'agit donc de carbone de fluor et de
chlore assemblée avec des molécules qui
sont saturés en aoùt carburer pu dire
aux jeunes et contrairement à là aussi
l'idée populaire qui ont un certain
nombre de gens le premièr usages qu'on
en a fait et n'a pas été de remplir les
bombes aérosol qui permettait de se
poudrer les cheveux ou entièrement sous
les bras
ça a essentiellement remplacer
l'ammoniaque dans les circuits
réfrigérant ça a été ça leur premièr
usage
ce sont des molécules qui sont dits
extrêmement grande stabilité chimique et
qui dit que c'est très stable
chimiquement dit que c'est pas toxique
un truc qui est très stable chimiques en
est un truc il réagit avec rien et en
particulier pas avec vos poumons pas
avec vos cellules si vous en respirer un
grand coup ce qui est pas exactement
quel d'ammoniac donc ça a remplacé
l'ammoniaque dans les chaînes du froid
et c'est ça qui a été lusage dominant au
départ des cfc puis quand on s'est rendu
compte que in fine et ça finissait par
arriver dans la haute atmosphère où
photo dissocié par les ultraviolets sa
libérer du chlore atomique qui n'était
pas spécialement bon pour l'ozone qui se
trouvait là on les a remplacés par du
substitut non saturés en halocarbures en
allogènes pardon donc dans lesquelles il
reste de l'hydrogène ce qui permet à ces
molécules d'être l'objet d'une
dégradation chimiques dans la basse
atmosphère
avant d'avoir le temps de monter dans la
haute atmosphère
mais ces gaz reste quand même des gaz à
effet de serre extrêmement significatif
alors on s'en sert toujours dans les
circuits de feed réfrigérant la
recherche de clim que fait vide as c'est
typiquement des halocarbures et on s'en
sert également dans des applications
industrielles diverses
et notamment comme solvant dans
l'industrie des semi conducteurs l'ozone
qui est également à gaz à effet de serre
à deux réservoirs distincts dans la
prospère qui ne communiquent pas entre
eux et l'ozone
je veux dire que c'est l'un des trucs
les plus compliqués à comprendre quand
vous avez affaire à des gens qui ne sont
pas dans ce genre d'activités à titre
professionnel
vous avez d'abord de l'ozone qui
apparaît et qui disparaît dans la
stratosphère donc la stratosphère
contient une concentration en ozone et
il s'agit bien d'une concentration en
ozone la couche d'ozone ça n'existe pas
couche devant pour moi une couche c'est
comme une couche de neige ou une couche
pour les dd c'est à dire un truc qui a
un début et une fin et entre les deux
c'est quelque chose de très compact 1
la couche d'ozone ces passants la couche
d'ozone c'est une concentration d'ozone
dans la stratosphère qui est plus
importante
en part relative que dans le reste de
l'atmosphère donc si vous faites un
profil de concentration d'ozone en
partant du sol
vous en avez une quantité donnée puis à
partir d'un certain moment ça se mit à
croître avant de se remettre à diminuer
mais on parle toujours de pour mille ou
% on est on est plutôt du côté du
premier lieu reste il s'agit pas d'avoir
99% d'ozone dans l'atmosphère à un
endroit donné dans l'atmosphère
cette zone il apparaît et disparaît sous
l'effet de la photo dissociation de
l'oxygène par les ultraviolets du soleil
alors ça c'est la résultante vous avez
de 25 réaction intermédiaire entre les
deux pour ceux que ça passionne bien
justement un bouquin de mégi qui
traitent du sujet cette zone il vit sa
vie sans quitter la stratosphère encore
cette zone vous ne voyez jamais près du
sol vis à vis de vous avez également
d'ozone près du sol c'est l'ozone des
fameux pique donc ils se trouveraient
dans la troposphère c'est à dire la plus
basses couches de l'atmosphère
cette zone là il apparaît et il
disparaît pour des causes qui ne sont
pas celles pour lesquelles il apparaît
et disparaît dans la haute atmosphère
en fait il apparaît à la suite d'une
réaction chimique et non pas d'une
réaction photochimique de dissociation
passé photochimique pardon mais c'est
pas de la dissociation
pure et simple il apparaît quand vous
mettez dans la marmite un cocktail de
polluants primaires c'est-à-dire des
oxydes d'azoté et des hydrocarbures
volatile on va dire des mets typiquement
du méthane des vapeurs d'essence etc
vous agitez ça un grand coup avec du
rayonnement solaire et vous apparaît de
l'ozone cet automne
comme vous le savez c'est un produit qui
est chimiquement très actif donc lui il
assez pur est tout simplement en
agressant une molécule qui lui avait
rien demandé
donc il va aller oxydé quelque chose
éventuellement l'intérieur de vos
poumons et c'est comme ça qu'ils secure
le jeune qui est dans la haute
atmosphère et tutto souhaitable parce
qu'il a le bon goût d'intercepter les
ultraviolets l'ozone à des raies
d'absorption dans l'ultraviolet l'ozone
qui est dans la basse atmosphère
en général on l'est moins parce que il a
également cet automne que la même
molécule un des raies d'absorption dans
l'infrarouge
donc il participe à l'effet de serre et
en plus il a la mauvaise idée de rentrer
dans vos poumons où il va aller au kid
skis tout ce qui s'y trouve est en
général les médecins trouvent que c'est
pas une très bonne idée il s'agit
évidemment de la même molécule encore
une fois mais vous avez deux cycles de
l'ozone sur terre qui ne communiquent
pas l'un avec l'autre
or donc les deux concentration évolué de
manière indépendante l'une de l'autre et
selon l'endroit où ils se trouvent
on aime bien ou on n'aime pas faut que
je vous ai dit ça je pense que vous
comprendrez la difficulté qu'ont nos
amis journalistes à essayer de résumer
tout ça en une phrase je vais maintenant
vous proposer à 2 panorama sur les
émissions d'ensemble de gaz à effet de
serre
deux des hommes la première constitue
une répartition tougas confondus par
secteur donc cette répartition tougas
confondus par secteur vous donne à peu
près le panorama suivant les industries
de l'énergie alors en fait dans là
dedans quand je vous ai montré le co2
tout à l'heure il y avait pas les
raffineries et la ja les raffineries
c'est pour ça si vous n'êtes pas
exactement à périmètre comparable
mais retenez l'idée que ça fait un quart
des émissions planétaires la
déforestation qui est la chaîne amont de
l'agriculture les décharges qui sont la
chaîne aval de l'agriculture et
l'agriculture stricto sensu
si vous mettez tout ça ensemble vous
voyez que ça vous fait quasiment
hier des émissions mondiales quasiment
un tiers des émissions mondiales
donc le processus agricole au sens large
avec ce qui l'a précédé et ce qui le
suit c'est à peu près un tiers des
émissions mondiales donc c'est
absolument majeur dans le problème vous
avez ici les procédés industriels qui ne
consiste pas à fabriquer ou des
carburants ou de l'électricité il s'agit
d'un des fabriqués par des brûlés
attente il s'agit des carburants ça fait
à peu près 20% des émissions là nos amis
de l'ipc c ils ont fait les andouilles
en mettant trois chiffres significatifs
il est évident ça n'a pas de sens de m 3
significatif sur les trucs vous avez des
bars d'erreur de 10 ou 20 ou 30 % et
enfin les bâtiments le chauffage direct
des bâtiments va faire un petit 10 % et
transport vont faire environ 13%
là encore si aérien terrestre maintenant
je vous propose une vue vue du
consommateur dans lesquels dans laquelle
je vais attribuer les émissions de
production de l'électricité aux gens qui
la consomment donc je suis dans le début
d'une logique de type bilan carbone ce
qui m'intéresse c'est pas temps de
regarder les émissions des centrales vu
les centrales mais de regarder les
émissions des centrales vue de la
personne qui branchent quelque chose
dans la prise donc je réintègre les
émissions de la production d'électricité
dans le compartiment industrie cantier
les industriels qui concerne
l'électricité et je réintègre les
émissions de production d'électricité
dans le compartiment bâtiment quand
c'est des bâtiments résidentiels et
tertiaires typiquement le genre
d'endroit où on est aujourd'hui qui
consomment de l'électricité et à ce
moment ça me donne et j'ai fait la même
chose pour la production des carburants
et à ce moment ça me donne le panorama
suivant qui est que y compris
l'électricité qu'ils consomment
alors ça change rien pour l'agriculture
et la déforestation
donc soit pas d'électricité là dedans un
peu donc la chaîne alimentaire me fait
toujours un tiers du problème les
procédés industriels me font un tiers du
problème si j'inclus l'électricité
qu'ils consomment
et si la console il a bien fallu à faire
donc la production des objets
manufacturés
c'est comme ça qu'il faut voir les
choses qu'on ne conduise à un tiers des
émissions planétaires
le fait d'avoir des logements
et des immeubles de bureaux et des
centres commerciaux etc
pour la partie émissions directes
directs et indirects liés à
l'électricité
c'est un quart du problème et vous voyez
que en ordre de grandeur
le fait d'avoir des objets manufacturés
ou le fait d'avoir des bâtiments cdma ce
qu'ils sont pas très loin d'être
équivalente donc la civilisation dans la
came s'endort l'occasion de rediscuter
la civilisation dans laquelle on va tout
le monde dans un bureau outre que c'est
pas possible parce que ça veut dire que
plus personne ne fait pousser les
patates et donc que tout le monde meurt
de faim la civilisation dans laquelle on
met tout le monde dans un bureau même si
c'était possible compte tenu de ce que
ça suppose comme consommation indirects
on verra ça au moment du bilan carbone
de faire ce genre de choses c'est
malheureusement pas suffisant pour
arriver à résoudre le problème et a
feint brut les transports qui certes
constituent en france un compartiment
dominant et croissant des émissions si
vous prenez le monde dans son ensemble
c'est pas ça qui domine pas dire que
j'ai un grand amoureux des voitures
nécessairement mais si vous prenez les
chiffres encore une fois les transports
c'est 15% des émissions ça vient
derrière les bâtiments si vous incluez
l'électricité qu'ils consomment et ça
vient derrière la production des
produits manufacturés si vous incluez
l'électricité que cela nécessite si vous
prenez la france alors là vous avez un
panorama un peu distincts et c'est dû à
la structure particulière de la
production d'électricité en france donc
les industries de l'énergie ne font que
10% du total
et là dedans vous avez à peu près 5 pour
les centrales et 5 pour les raffineries
l'industrie hors production d'énergie
fait un quart
l'agriculture fait un carrasso ça dépend
beaucoup du format de comptabilisation
ça peut faire 18 % dans certains ça fait
26 % ici en fait ça dépend si vous
comptez brut net etc
le résidentiel tertiaire donc les
bâtiments sans l'électricité qu'ils
consomment
le chauffage c'est 20% et le transport
c'est l'important donc vous voyez que
seul et non le pays auquel vous vous
intéressez ce camembert que je vous ai
présenté juste avant avec quelques
masses qui domine de manière
significative
vous allez toujours les retrouver c'est
très rare que vous trouviez un pays où
la masse qu'était à 30 descend à deux
baies les proportions peuvent quand même
varier de manière significative donc
retenait qu'on a en gros
trois ou quatre sources dominantes de
gaz à effet de serre sur la planète
fabriquer des objets manufacturés bon
j'ai habité habité avoir des bâtiments
soit pour son travail soit tour son
logement voilà en gros les trois grandes
sources
c'est exactement d'un quotidien c'est
très exactement notre quotidien ça nous
amène à la conclusion que je vous lira
qui est que à la différence des cfc dont
je parlais tout à l'heure qui
représentait en gros un chiffre
d'affaires pour leurs producteurs de
quelques dizaines de milliards de
dollars dans un monde dont le pib est de
30 mille ou 40 milliards de dollars qui
étaient concentrées sur quelques usages
très spécifique pour lesquels au surplus
en payant juste un peu plus cher on a
des substituts technique c'était un
problème facile à régler un problème
facile à jour là vous avez affaire à un
problème que vous preniez la montre où
la valve qui est imbriqué dans chacun de
nos actes quotidiens d'aujourd'hui dont
l'usagé est à l'origine non pas de 1
pour mille mais de 100% ou à peu près du
pib mondial
vous comprenez avec ça que la facilité
ou la difficulté à résoudre le problème
n'a strictement rien de comparable avec
ce qui s'est passé sur le cfc et l'ozone
stratosphérique
ça n'a rien de comparable absolument on
est bien comparer les deux en l'espèce
ça n'a absolument rien de comparable
alors ouais mais également d'autres
espèces dans l'atmosphère qui engendre
l'effet inverse de celui dont on vient
de parler tout à l'heure de manière un
peu un peu large c'est-à-dire le
réchauffement qui sont des espèces
refroidi sentent en ce sens qu'elles
vont soit directement réfléchir soit
conduire à l'apparition de cahors qui
vont réfléchir le rayonnement solaire
on parle là de ce qu'on appelle les
aérosols ou les précurseurs d'aérosols
alors là aérosols c'est bien évidemment
pas les bombes aérosol
s'agit pas d'aller lac et l'atmosphère
vous savez qu'en physique un aérosol
c'est une suspension dans un gaz de
particuliers qui louent solide et là
c'est bien de ça dont il s'agit
un nuage typiquement c'est un aérosol
quand vous passez de balle et un peu
énergiquement vous créez un aérosol ce
que vous avez au dessus de los angeles
ou de paris quand vous avez des tas de
cochonneries
par beau temps c'est un aérosol et par
les gaz et les poussières l'année mais
deux types de composés qui conduit soit
des aérosols soit a qui vont modifier la
formation des aérosols naturel est en
fait la source principale pour tout ça
ça va être le dioxyde de soufre quand
vous émettez du dioxyde de soufre vous
conduisez à l'apparition de sulfate dans
l'atmosphère et c'est sulfate ils ont la
particularité un d'être directement des
réflecteurs du rayonnement solaire et
surtout deux de servir de noyaux de
condensation pour la vapeur d'eau
présente dans l'atmosphère et ça va donc
vous modifier la structure des nuages et
en particulier ça va vous augmentez
souvent la persistance et la taille des
gouttelettes dans les nuages
ça va rendre les gouttelettes plus petit
ça va diminuer la faculté a précipité
des nuages et ce afin de favoriser
l'apparition donc où la couverture
nuageuse basse pour la couverture
nuageuse basse un écran réfléchissant
sur le rayonnement solaire qui
l'emportent sur l'effet de serre qu'elle
induit par ce qu'il ya de la vapeur
d'eau donc en gros quand vous faites
apparaître un cumulus globalement vous
refroidit c'est l'atmosphère vous
rafraîchissez la surface c'est l'inversé
avec les nuages au quand vous faites
apparaître ainsi russe
globalement vous réchauffer la surface
parce que le nuage est encore
suffisamment translucide au rayonnement
solaire pour que l'effet global
réflexion plus effet de serre induit
soit un réchauffement net de la surface
donc les aérosols et ses précurseurs
d'aérosols induisent un refroidissement
et si vous comparez les faits le forçage
radiatif positifs induits par le surplus
de gaz à effet de serre qu'on a mis et
le forçage radiatif négatif induit par
le surplus d'aérosols que nous
rajouter dans l'atmosphère vous arrivez
quand à m un résultat qui est
globalement positif
comme disait l'autre c'est à dire que
pour le moment l'effet de serre
supplémentaires qu'on a rajouté dans
l'atmosphère l'emportent sur les
aérosols supplémentaire qu'on a rajouté
dans l'atmosphère et il ya une
différence très importante entre les
deux c'est que la durée de persistants
ans après l'arrêt des émissions de ces
gaz là ce conte ancien clouant
millénaire alors que la durée de
persistance après l'arrêt des émissions
de ces composés la seconde en semaine et
comme en plus ils sont associés de la
pollution locale que le dioxyde de
soufre ça fait d'acide sulfurique une
fois dans l'air et personne n'est très
pressé d'avoir l'acide sulfurique qui
tombe un peu partout eh bien on a plutôt
tendance à chercher à limiter les
émissions donc à l'avenir et mais par
contre les très fortes émissions
d'aérosols qu'il y a eu qui ont eu lieu
pendant les trente glorieuses à un
moment où l'industrie a tourné à plein
régime et où on avait des tas de
combustibles fossiles souffre et pour
lesquelles on laissait le dioxyde de
soufre partir de l'atmosphère
c'est une des explications qu'on avance
parfois pour expliquer la raison pour
laquelle la température planétaire a
cessé d'augmenter entre 40 et 70 voire a
légèrement décru en 1940 et 1970 l'une
des explications possibles
indépendamment de la variabilité
naturelle c'est l'augmentation très
significative des émissions d'aérosols
qui ont contribué à à ce moment à
contrebalancer l'effet de serre naissant
et puis depuis les émissions d'aérosols
ou plutôt commence à baisser alors que
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
augmenter l'effet cumulatif augmente ce
qui explique que cette affaire sorte du
bruit de fond maintenant je vais
maintenant essayer de vous expliquer
comment est ce qu'on fait une simulation
climatique à partir de tout ce que vous
avez vu jusqu'à maintenant
alors pour faire une simulation
climatique il faut deux choses il faut
comprendre comment fonctionne le système
climatique et il faut par ailleurs faire
une hypothèse qui est nécessairement une
hypothèse sur la perturbation que les
hommes y apportez donc une simulation
climatique
bénard par la force des choses je dis
bien par la force des choses avec une
hypothèse sur la manière dont les hommes
vont se comporter sur la durée de la
simulation et comme évidemment l'avenir
n'est pas écrit ça veut dire que vous
avez
entre est quelque chose qui est un
scénario n'est pas une prévision de
l'avenir qui est les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre que l'humanité pourrait
être amené à faire pour le moment les
physiciens
il travaille avec une fourchette de
scénario ou le plus bas c'est que les
émissions augmentent légèrement au cours
du 21e siècle avant de diminuer alors
que le plus haut c'est les éditions qui
sont progressivement x 4 toute la
question étant bien évidemment de savoir
si ce scénario il a une quelconque
chance de se réaliser compte tenu des
contraintes ce que je vous ai exposé sur
les combustibles fossiles et cette
question se pose parce que les gens qui
ont fait les scénarios ils ne le sont
pas dans le domaine de la géologie des
vocables des hydrocarbures donc pour le
moment il ya un débat assez vif qui
existent entre certains géologues
pétroliers et les gens qui font de la
simulation numérique du climat les
premiers 10 ans ou 2d avec des arguments
qui sont à mon avis largement recevable
pour partie qui est que la fourchette
haute des scénarios c'est pas la peine
de les explorer parce que on est en
train de perdre son temps au niveau des
éditions c'est très peu probable qu'on
voit ce genre de choses arrive une fois
que vous avez vos scénarios d'émissions
alors vous faites passer ça dans un
premier étage de modélisation qu'est ce
qu'on appelle un cycle du carbone et
vous avez l'évolution future de votre
stock atmosphériques de gaz à effet de
serre donc vous allez spéculer sur le
débit du robinet et à partir de là vous
avez un premier étage de modélisation
qui vous donne la quantité d'eau dans la
baignoire
une fois que vous avez l'évolution de
votre niveau en gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère stock atmosphériques
de gaz à effet de serre allait vous fait
passer ça dans un modèle de climat rac
quand je vous ai tout à l'heure c'est
flight simulator appliquée au cna et
vous avez les paramètres climatiques
dès votre modèle qui varie donc votre
modèle vous dit ça va chauffer ça a
chauffé plus ici que la salle à ce
regard là les précipitations vont
évoluer comme ceux ci comme cela les
grandes zones de couverture de la
végétation je les vois se déplacer comme
ceux ci comme cela et c'est le système
est asservi dans tous les sens et en
particulier une chose que je vous
montrerai c'est que l'évolution des
paramètres climatiques va au retour
avoir une influence toutes choses égales
par ailleurs sur le niveau du stock
atmosphériques de gaz à effet de serre
donc le cycle du carbone
et le système climatique sont asservis
l'un comme de l'autre et c'est un
asservissement qui va dans les deux sens
l'un comme de l'autre et vous ne pouvez
pas avoir un système climatique qui
varient encore une fois sans que les
cycles du carbone varie et puis vous
avez une autre boucle de rétroaction qui
pour le moment n'est pas prise en compte
dans les modèles mais qui figuraient
dans le rapport du club de rome dont je
vous ai parlé au cours de la première
leçon qui consisterait parce que la
question n'est pas dans le modèle encore
une fois à se poser la question qui est
quelle pression sur l'activité humaine
est ce que cette évolution va exercer et
qui viendrait invalider au bout d'un
certain temps
l'évolution que j'ai imaginé pour les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre parce
qu il est bien évident vous allez le
voir avec les résultats
alors là il s'agit pas de science il
s'agit de je suis presque dans la
religion mais à titre personnel je ne
crois pas une seconde par une seconde au
fait qu'on puisse avoir une activité
industrielle prospèrent sur la deuxième
moitié du xxième siècle qui permettrait
de faire augmenter les émissions sans
cesse dans un monde dans lequel on
s'achemine vers une transition
climatique de lors de cinq degrés en un
siècle
je n'y crois pas une seconde je crois
que dans ce genre de monde on aura
déliquescence généralisée et en
particulier l'activité économique
actuelle se cassera la gueule et donc il
sera pas question d'avoir les éditions
qui aura donc le mais ça c'est une
boucle de rétroaction qui aujourd'hui
encore une fois est d'une certaine
manière par modélisable facilement sauf
que les dynamicien des systèmes qui
avait bossé om haïti à l'époque du
rapport du club de rome parce que ces
pays aient fait le boulot avait dit que
avec un modèle relativement agrégé va au
bout d'un certain temps la pression sur
l'activité humaine en retour liées à des
atteintes significative à
l'environnement qui est un facteur de
production et bien engendrera en
particulier une baisse structurelle de
l'activité économique des hommes
donc c'est quelque chose sur lequel ça
peut vous paraître un peu tiré par les
cheveux mais c'est absolument essentiel
parce que psychologiquement on est tous
big orné de la même manière à partir du
moment où on vous dit dans le journal
la température pourrait monter de temps
en 2100 eh bien on vous
implicitement la conclusion que les
premiers emmerdements sont pour le 1er
janvier 2000 101 puisque s'il y avait
des emmerdements massifs avant 2100 bas
l'évolution continuerait pas jusqu'à son
terme
donc à chaque fois et ça c'est un truc
que vous allez retrouver dans votre
métier
quel que soit votre métier et quel que
soit le domaine et que vous parlez de
changements climatiques ou pas dès lors
que l'on vous donne une prolongation
tendanciel qui va jusqu'à une date
donnée
le simple fait de la prendre comme
hypothèse de départ
ça veut dire que vous achetez l'idée
qu'il ne se passe rien de perturbant
avant l'échéance de la prolongation
j'insiste vraiment là-dessus vous ne
pouvez pas savoir la quantité d'effets
délétères qui sont liées à ce genre de
choses
pour en revenir aux cours précédant le
fait que l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie
10 en prolongation tendancielle la
consommation d'énergie c'est ça monte
jusqu'à tel endroit en 2030 dans la tête
de tous absolument tous nos gouvernants
ça mais l'idée que tout n'importe quel
ennui
et pour après le 1er janvier 2031 donc
là c'est exactement pareil c'est pas
parce que c'est une simulation faite sur
ordinateur avec un scénario en entrée et
qui est perpétuellement croissant que ça
veut dire que les premiers ennuis sont
pour le 22ème siècle
c'est pas vrai c'est un truc qu'il faut
qu'il faut se sortir de la tête
et même si encore une fois c'est pas
facile donc je vous le disais le premier
étage de la fusée
c'est de savoir ce que vont faire les
hommes à l'avenir alors y aura pic de
toute façon mais la question est de
savoir s'il est un peu plus tard ou un
peu plus tôt alors si on regarde les
choses un tout petit peu plus en détails
en fait les gens travaillent avec des
gaz différencier au niveau des scénarios
d'émissions en ce qui concerne le co2
qui est le principal gaz concernés quand
je vous disais on parle des missions qui
sont de l'ordre de 7 milliards de tonnes
de carbone en 2000 et puis ça monte
jusqu'à 9 pour le scénario plus bas
avant de redescendre en gros à 5
c'est ce que dans la suite de mes
planches chapelle des émissions quasi
constante
en gros ça monte un peu ça descend un
peu après vous avez un scénario en rouge
ici là qui correspond à un scénario
charbon ou celui d'à à mon sens restent
compatibles avec les ressources fossiles
inventoriées
et il porte le doux patronyme de à un b
celui là aient enfin ici vous avez un
scénario dans lequel les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sont 20 de co2 sont
multipliées par quatre d'ici à 2100 et
sauf à ce qu'on sache exploités
industriellement les hydrates de méthane
on découvre quatre fois la quantité de
charbon qu'on imagine que la croûte
terrestre comporte aujourd'hui celui là
me paraît complètement improbable il
paraît d'autant plus improbable que la
rétroaction climatique si sadique ça se
chargera à mon avis de faire baisser les
émissions avant 2100 ici vous avez les
émissions de protoxyde d'azoté de
méthane vous voyez aussi que le scénario
bas en gros c'est les émissions quasi
constante et le scénario où c'est un
doublement ou et en gros un doublement
de ces gaz est ici vous avez les
émissions de so2 donc le précurseur
d'aérosols dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure et là vous voyez par contre que
dans tous les scénarios
on a pris l'hypothèse qu'après une
période transitoire de hausse éventuels
liés à l'industrialisation des pays qui
aujourd'hui sont en train de bâtir leur
aciérie leur ciment thriller et c'est un
truc qui conduisent à des émissions et
leurs centrales à charbon eh bien ça
allait se mettre à baisser encore une
fois tout ça ça n'existe aux thèses mais
il faut bien savoir lesquels
d'hypothèses
on a fonctionné parce qu'alors là pour
le coup je vais me permettre de
chatouiller les gens qui font de
l'économie
un résultat en économie est aussi bon
que la qualité des hypothèses qu'on a
pris en entrée il faut bien se garder
l'exactitude de la formule avec
l'exactitude du résultat c'est qu'on
confond toujours les deux enfin si vous
appliquez des mathématiques juste à une
hypothèse farfelue
vous obtiendrez un résultat farfelu
c'est c'est le gène équation exact n'est
pas un gène dominant d'anvers récessif
donc il faut que vous ayez à la fois une
équation exactes et les hypothèses exact
alors j'en reviens à ce que je disais
sur le premier étage de la fusée donc là
maintenant on va passer au deuxième le
deuxième c'est je passe des émissions
vers concentration alors ici vous avez
une mise en perspective de la
concentration atmosphérique en co2 sur
le dernier millénaire c'est ce que je
voulais montrer tout à l'heure la
manière dont ça a évolué au cours du 20e
siècle
est ce que ça pourrait donner à l'avenir
avec dans le premier cas de figure des
émissions qui reste quasi constante et
dans le deuxième cas de figure avec le
scénario alors
scénario je lui ai donné un nom j'ai dit
que c'était le monde entier qui
convergeaient vers les émissions d'un
habitant de la pologne de l'an 2000
alors il se trouve que j'ai fait ce
petit truc là avant le référendum
européen que je n'ai strictement rien
contre les polonais qu'il soit long
billet ou qu'il fasse autre chose
il se trouve simplement que les polonais
ont les premières réserves de charbon en
europe et que le monde dans lequel on
cherche à faire croître les émissions
tant que ça passe est un monde dans
lequel on tape très violemment dans le
charbon parce que c'est essentiellement
ça qui va servir à fournir le carburant
et donc ça veut dire que l'as le mix
énergétique va se rapprocher du mix
énergétique de la pologne actuelle
alors là on parle pas pour le moment de
la séquestration mais je vous en
parlerai plus tard mais c'est voilà donc
c'est dans un monde dans lequel on
laisse le suivre de partir dans l'air ce
qui est quand même le cas pour une bonne
partie des usages et bien ce monde là
donc si vous conjuguez la croissance
démographique et une convergence des
modes de vie vers la manière dont vie en
polonais d'aujourd'hui eh bien vous
arrivez au scénario
alors si vous avez bien entendu
comme c'est un scénario auquel je ne
crois pas pour des raisons physiques
ça veut dire que le monde ne peut pas
c'est pas le scénario socio économique
on peut proposer en ayant une chance de
l'atteindre proposé à l'ensemble des
habitants de la planète de se mettre à
vivre comme un colonel aujourd'hui voilà
si niveau de convergence il ya il sera
beaucoup plus d'accent ensuite on va
donc faire passer cette variation de la
concentration de gaz à effet serre dans
un modèle dont je voulais tout à l'heure
un modèle c'est flight simulator sauf
que c'est pas facile à tort c'est qui va
de civils à tort donc en gros ça revient
à représenter sur ordinateur le
fonctionnement réel du système
climatique
alors je vous ai dit que dans le système
climatique y avait des compartiments
fluide qui étaient les compartiments ou
quasi fluide qui étaient les
compartiments qui domine l évolution du
système à l'échelle du siècle pour
modéliser ses compartiments fluides ou
quasi fluide
vous savez que l'ordinateur n'aime pas
beaucoup l'infini donc on ne peut pas
représenter le monde avec une infinité
de points est en fait compte tenu de la
puissance de calcul disponible ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va découper le
monde en boîte à chaussures et où
exactement les compartiments fluide du
monde à boîte à chaussures et on va
considérer chaque boîte à chaussures
comme un tout homogène
bon
des parallélépipèdes pourpier très plat
parce que la maille sur l'horizontale et
typiquement de l'ordre de la centaine de
kilomètres alors que la maille sur la
verticale est typiquement le genre de la
centaine de mètres j'ai effectivement
des pieds extrêmement plein mais c'est
ça la manière dont on s'y prend et on
considère que chaque cube chaque par les
pipettes qu'on obtient ainsi est un tout
homogène à l'intérieur duquel le vent
est le même partout
la température est la même partout les
précipitations semaine partout etc alors
de temps en temps ce n'est pas aussi
simple que ça on a produit des gradients
à l'intérieur de la maille
mais ça reste des trucs qui sont gérées
avec des paramètres globaux s'est pas il
n'y a pas une représentation explicite
des processus qui sont sous les chaînes
de la rai et en particulier il n'y a pas
de représentation explicite dans les
modèles de la convection atmosphérique à
petite échelle c'est à dire celle qui
fait apparaître les nuages et les
précipitations locales
donc ça c'est quand même une grosse
limitation pour avoir des évolutions
régionales et de la visibilité sur les
presque d'ailleurs plus d'orage par
exemple impossible de répondre à la
question avec ce genre de avec ce genre
d'outil le les modèles
ils sont exactement comme les jeux vidéo
ça je suis sûr que ça vous est familier
ceux de 1970 1 le pacman de mes études
c'est pas exactement ce qu'on va trouver
aujourd'hui c'est exactement pareil pour
les modèles qui permettent de faire de
la simulation climatique
ils ont bénéficié comme le reste de
l'augmentation de la puissance de calcul
dans les années 70 ce joujou je vous la
fait courte est bonne dans les années 70
on représentait essentiellement le sol
avec pas d'eau ou presque la variation
de la quantité de co2 dans l'atmosphère
un cycle de l'eau extrêmement globale et
paramétrer et aujourd'hui on est capable
d'avoir des modèles vous épargner
d'animation j'aurais pu dans lesquels on
représente l'océan avec sa dynamique la
végétation avec sa dynamique la chimie
atmosphérique avec sa dynamique
évidemment les échanges d'énergie
évidemment les aérosols qui sont apparus
etc etc
la dynamique en ce qui concerne la glace
de mer etc
donc en gros chaque spécialité dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure les
glaciologues les biologistes et machin
etc a construit un doux dans un coin et
puis ensuite aride et ensembliers qui
raccorde les divers bout les uns aux
autres créer les interfaces qui permet
de créer un grand modèle couplé dans
lequel chaque compartiment répond aux
autres c'est ça l'idée
donc les sectes est exactement comme
quand vous faites warcraft chacun décide
son petit personnage
et puis après vous intégrer tout ça dans
un truc que ce cas là de se parler
la maille du du modèle a également
fortement diminué au cours des dernières
décennies reflétant cela l'augmentation
de la puissance informatique disponible
et entre alors les acronymes que vous
avez là font référence au rapport
d'évaluation du giec dont je vous ai un
tout petit peu parlé alors le giec c'est
quoi je vais faire une incidence à cette
occasion le giec c'est une revue de
presse mais une revue de presse pré
particulière on demande à des
scientifiques de faire une compilation
de tout ce qui se publie et dans la
littérature scientifique des années
écoulées et d'en faire un résumé en 800
pages
c'est ça un rapport du giec
c'est ça un rapport du giec donc la
seule source d'information qui est prise
dans les rapports du giec
c'est ce qui paraît dans les revues
scientifiques à comité de lecture on se
contrefout de savoir ce que tel ou tel a
déclaré dans le monde c'est pas un sujet
et par ailleurs ce sont les gens du
domaine qui font la synthèse des
informations qui sont les seuls à
comprendre je veux dire dans un colloque
de médecins
c'est rare qu'on invite à un boulanger
ou un garagiste en général on considère
que c'est les médecins entre eux qui
sont les mieux outillés pour faire la
synthèse de leurs propres travaux
un rapport du giec ça marche exactement
dans la manière je vous rappelle encore
une fois que c'est un document que pas
une personne qui le contestent nalu d'un
bout à l'autre pas d'une
par ailleurs dans un rapport de 800
pages vous vous doutez bien que si on
fait 800 pages et pas 3 c'est parce que
ya des nuances dans tous les sens c'est
parce qu'elle est conditionnel dans tous
les sens c'est parce qu'il ya des
précisions et des limites aux
connaissances acquises et au contraire
la description précise des sujets qui
font encore débat qui sont exposées avec
toutes leurs nuances c'est parce que la
langue française comporte plus de trois
mots qui ont fait un gros dictionnaires
et voilà c'est exactement pareil c'est
utile alors plus de trois bons pour
faire des nuances et bien là c'est
pareil c'est parce que la science qui se
préoccupe de ce processus a des tas de
direction dans lesquels elle cherche et
l'état de résultats définitifs ou
intermédiaire à proposer et des tas de
zones d'ombré à mettre en lumière
pardonnez-moi le mauvais jeu de mots que
ont fait un rapport de 800 pages et
encore une fois pas un article d'une
demi page
donc c'est quelque chose si ça vous
amuse je vous conseille même si ça vous
amuse pas je vous conseille l'exercice
suivant sur le site du giec qui est ipcc
point chc cci international challenge et
je vous donnerai peut-être un contrôle
là dessus allez télécharger le rapport
lisez en trois pages et regarder si à
votre avis c'est quelque chose qui est
acquis c'est accessible
regardez acquis c'est accessible ça
c'est une très bonne idée que l'on
contrôle ça voilà il faites vous votre
propre opinion là dessus
les modèles dont je vous ai parlé ils
sont évidemment par donc on finir sur le
rapport du giec vous avez évidemment à
londres un long processus de revue
critique c'est à dire que le draft qui a
été écrit par monsieur ans on va le
soumettre à monsieur b de la même
spécialité pour qu'ils disent est ce que
oui ou non on ça correspond à ma manière
de voir les choses
sinon pourquoi etc j'avais en débat
entre spécialistes qui prend des années
et qui permet d'accoucher d'un document
encore une fois qui expose le problème
dans toute sa complexité et avec toutes
ses nuances
j'en reviens à mes modèles
c'est comme avant la commercialisation
d'un jeu vidéo on est sûr que ça va bien
faire ce qui a marqué sur la notice
commercial voilà c'est exactement pareil
avant de commencer à regarder l'avenir
on va déjà commencer par voir si le
modèle reproduit à peu près correctement
ce qui s'est passé dans la zone dans
laquelle on l'a de l'instrumentation
donc on va faire tourner le modèle en le
faisant partir de 1900 et on va regarder
ce qu'il raconte sur l'évolution du
système climatique
alors vous avez ici une des graphiques
qui s'interprète de la manière suivante
la combe noire
c'est la valeur la plus probable de
l'évolution régionale de la température
sur la période considérée
donc là en l'occurrence sur le xxème
siècle la plage rose
sellal enveloppe un terreau modèle donc
c'est la zone dans laquelle se situe la
totalité des simulations qu'on a pu
faire avec la vingtaine de modèles qui
ont été utilisés parce que chaque équipe
de physiciens un peu riche de par le
monde a sa propre équipe de à son propre
modèle donc j'avais à peu près 20
modèles 28 simulation numérique qui
existe dans le monde
en france vous en avez deux ou trois
météo france en marin le laboratoire de
météorologie dynamique
elie ps elle en est un autre et puis il
y en a un troisième cerfacs surcroît son
propre modèle également en grande
bretagne 10 ans - qui est très célèbre
qui est celui du hadley center etc
la nasa centre pro model enfin pour
brest où tout le monde a son modèle et
on va alimenter les modèles avec les
mêmes hypothèses
je préfère c'est important d'avoir des
scénarios sur lesquels on est tous
d'accord comme ça on compare les
résultats et on va regarder ce qu'a donc
sur le xxème siècle toutes les
simulations qui sont faites avec les
modèles utilisés se situe dans l'
enveloppe prose qui est situé là quand
on prend en compte les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre et se situe dans la
blouse bleue qui est là si on ne prend
pas en compte les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre alors les deux résultats
absolument majeur que vous pouvez voir
sur ces graphiques c'est que 1
quand on prend en compte les gaz à effet
de serre à peu près tous les modèles
sont dans les clous s'il s'agit de
reproduire la tendance si on ne prend
pas en compte les gaz à effet de serre
vous n'avez plus aucun modèle je dis
bien plus aucun modèle qui est capable
de repos
fuir ce qui s'est passé à partir des
années 1970 il s'agit pas que j'en ai
quelques-uns qui reproduisent et
quelques-uns qui reproduisent pas si
vous en avez pas un seul qui est capable
de reproduire
par contre sur la première moitié du 20e
siècle
eh bien vous voyez que ces outils ne
permettent pas de discriminer en mettant
un point final au débat
l'évolution avec influence humaine et
l'évolution sans influence humaine
en d'autres termes sur la première
moitié du 20e siècle ces outils ne sont
pas capables d'apporter un point final à
la question qui est est ce que le climat
se serait comporté de la même manière
sans nous ou pas par contre ils sont
capables d'apporter une réponse pour la
deuxième moitié du 20e siècle
depuis les années 1970 qui est si le
climat aurait pu ce qu'en face ils
climat s'était comporté de toute façon
comme ça sans nous aujourd'hui personne
là l'explication c'est ça que ça
signifie et en particulier l'une des
choses qu'on peut évacuer de la
discussion
sauf effet alors là vraiment con très
compliqué qu'on n'aurait pas vu celle
influence du soleil parce que si c'est
ça qui explique le réchauffement des
températures observée depuis 1970 assez
logiquement on devrait s'attendre à ce
que les températures aient plus augmenté
et là où il ya beaucoup de soleil que là
où il y en a pas beaucoup sauf mécanisme
de transfert qu'on n'aurait absolument
pas vu or il se trouve que c'est
exactement l'inversé qui s'est passé sur
les 30 dernières années les températures
augmentent plus vite au pôle que aux
tropiques
elle augmente plus vite la nuit que le
jour aux moyennes latitudes et elle
augmente plus vite hiver que l'été au
moyen d'un futur et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est beaucoup plus cohérent
avec une interception renforcée du
rayonnement terrestre que avec une
augmentation du rayonnement solaire
parce que l'augmentation renfoncer du
rayonnement perez qui a lieu la nuit et
le jour
la surface terrestre elle tombe pas à 0
kelvin la nuit donc l'interception
renforcée du rayonnement terrestre se
manifeste la nuit et le jour est donc va
être proportionnellement beaucoup plus
visible quand vous n'avez pas de soleil
que quand vous en avez donc c'est
parfaitement cohérent avec le
renforcement de l'effet de serre que le
relèvement des températures et
préférentiellement lieu à un moment où
un lieu où vous n'avez pas de soleil
plutôt que à un moment où à un lieu où
vous avez beaucoup de soleil
alors maintenant si on regarde on va
commencer à regarder ce que ça signifie
sur la température planétaire cette
affaire la première signification
vous l'avez ici cette courbe qui est
gradué en degrés à 1 0 de référence qui
est la moyenne planétaire des deux
dernières décennies du xxème siècle donc
là encore c'est une double intégral
temporel et géographique et la plage de
temps ses 20 ans qui vont de 1980 à 2000
pour faire simple vous voyez qu au cours
du 20e siècle la température était
globalement plus basse avec une barre
d'erreur sur la première moitié du 20e
siècle qui reste significatif parce que
les relevés de température à cette
époque ne sont pas nécessairement
homogène à tel endroit où vous allez
prendre la température à 9 heures du
matin à tel endroit où vous allez
apprendre à 8h à tel endroit vous allez
la reprendre sous abri comme ceci est à
tel autre endroit où vous allez
reprendre sous abri comme cela et puis
je vous rappelle que les deux tiers de
la surface terrestre couvert d'océan et
les routes commerciales au milieu du
pacifique en 1905 il y en a quand même
pas énormément donc pour aller faire des
relevés de température c'est pas
extraordinaire en pratique les relevés
de température
la couverture planétaire s'obtient de
manière large depuis l'avènement des
satellites
avant c'était très difficile d'avoir des
relevés météo les années soixante dix
ans après beaucoup imaginent plusieurs
choses à la mia et vous avez vous
constaté par donc on finir là-dessus que
l'amplitude de la variation xxème siècle
c'est la fraction degrés lors de 0,5 un
peu plus 0,6 maintenant on peut se poser
un certain nombre de questions pour
l'avenir alors la première question
c'est l'hypothèse polpot je tue tout le
monde donc la concentration
atmosphérique reste constante puisque le
co2 va passer curé il agresse
quid et bien le talon qu'on est à peu
près assurée de prendre de toute façon
c'est un demi degré
l'élévation supplémentaires et monsieur
james hansen à la nasa il pense que sur
une période de temps plus longue
on est à peu près assurée de prendre
déjà 3 degrés à cause des rétroactions
landes du système qui sont pas prises en
compte dans les modèles et en
particulier la rétroaction lente sur
l'albédo une hypothèse qui en ce moment
fait débat évidemment mais qui qui a
quelques arguments qui malheureusement
qu'on peut pas écarter d'un revers de la
main ensuite vous prenez une hypothèse
qui est que les émissions restent quasi
constante donc c'est le scénario du bas
dans ce que je vous ai montré et à ce
moment l'ordre de grandeur de ce qui se
passe c'est plus de degrés en fait c'est
plus de degrés avec un peu de chance ça
pourrait être plus un avec pas beaucoup
de chances du tout ça pourrait plus 4
vous avez ensuite le scénario charbon et
donc les émissions mondiales qui doubla
vous prenez plus trois mais ça peut être
significativement plus élevé je vous
montrerai après quelle signification on
peut accorder sa et enfin bon scénario
très élevé on est entre les 4 et 6 que
je vous ai évoqué tout à l'heure si je
met en perspective cette élévation de
température non plus avec le dernier
siècle mais avec le dernier millénaire
voici ce que ça donne vous avez sur
cette courbe le 0 de référence il est
ici est toujours la température moyenne
de la planète alors cette fois ci c'est
pas sur les deux dernières décennies du
xxème siècle c'est sur l'année 1990 mais
ça change pas grand chose
eh bien vous voyez que la température
moyenne de la planète
exactement de l'hémisphère nord ici avec
une barre d'erreurs qui est de la du
demi degré de part et d'autre et est
légèrement inférieur à la température
actuelle d'une fraction de degré on va
dire sur le dernier millénaire donc là
il s'agit de l'hémisphère nord c'est là
qu'on a des indicateurs qui permettent
de reconstruire la température en
quantité la plus abondante les cernes
d'arbres notamment mais pas seulement et
20e siècles vous voyez l'élévation de
température qui est parfaitement
discernable avec la comme je vous le
disais le petit décrochement de 40 à 70
ce qui est aussi parfaitement
discernable mais vous voyez que avec des
émissions qui resterait simplement
constante en fait au 21ème siècle
changement de rechange d'ordre de
grandeur
et si vous ne devait retenir qu'une
seule chose importante dans cette
affaire c'est que le problème n'est pas
derrière nous ils demandent le problème
est devant nous
la question de savoir si le changement
climatique est déjà là c'est une
question parfaitement secondaire
c'est parfaitement secondaire toutes
proportions gardées c'est un peu comme
si quelqu'un qui fume depuis trois mois
vous vous demandez si la petite touche
de février au matin c'est le tabac où
s'est pas le tabac c'est une question
parfaitement secondaire
la question principale est plus tard
c'est très exactement la même chose en
ce qui concerne le changement climatique
il se trouve que j'en reviens toujours à
ça parce que même quand vous êtes à
l'école c'est une source significative
d'information j'ai vu des tas de
journaux qui traînent là une caméra de
télévision
ça se braquent sur ce qui s'est passé la
semaine dernière ça ne se brade pas sur
ce qui va se passer dans 50 ans donc la
question centrale dans le débat
médiatique c est ce que le changement
climatique est déjà là c'est pas la
question centrale
en ce qui concerne le débat de société
la question centrale en ce qui concerne
le débat de société
c'est où sont les risques pour l'avenir
dans la prolongation de ce qu'on est en
train de faire en ce moment donc avec
des émissions mondiales qui reste
simplement content quand on est là avec
des émissions qui n'arriveront pas on
serait là vous voyez que dans tous les
cas de figure on change
l'amplitude et on change la dérive et
dans tous les quartiers alors en fait il
faut comprendre cette approche comme une
approche probabiliste
c'est à dire que quand vous faites
tourner votre modèle de 153 fois il va
vous donner des distributions de
délégations température et le milieu de
la course que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure donc le milieu de cette courbe
n'a la partie qui est en couleur foncée
là au milieu c'est tout simplement le
sommet deux magots syed au casino sienne
dans la distribution des résultats que
vous avez là vous avez fait tourner
votre modèle 120 x et il vous dit bas la
moyenne de tout ce que j'ai trouvé en
tournant sans ma foi se balade plutôt
par là ça ne veut absolument pas dire
comme vous le savez très bien sinon
jamais personne ne jouerait le gagnerai
dire la roulette
ni au loto que de temps en temps vous
vous trouvez pas sur la partie droite de
m distribution dans tant d'autres termes
il ne ferait pas prendre les fourchettes
d'élévation de température rapportés par
les médias comme des bornes supérieur
infranchissable c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut prendre le résultat il faut
comprendre le résultat comme
raisonnablement on va prendre au moins
temps est au dessus on sait pas c'est
plutôt comme ça qu'il faut prendre là le
résultat donc dans le scénario charbon
et on prend au moins 3 ou 4 degrés et
options sais pas peut très bien
reprendre 6 8 10 15 c'est bon est-ce que
5 degrés c'est beaucoup pas beaucoup
vous avez vu que c'était beaucoup plus
que la variabilité climatique naturelle
à l'échelle du millénaire sur
l'hémisphère nord
en fait 5 degrés c'est très exactement
le réchauffement que la planète a connu
entre la dernière ère glaciaire est
aujourd'hui 5 degrés c'est ce qui marque
une des glaciations une des glaciations
conduit à un tout petit changement de
géographie puisque au moment de la
dernière ère glaciaire tout le nord de
l'europe et le canada étaient recouverts
de quelques kilomètres de glace je sais
pas s'il ya des grenoblois dans la salle
mais à l'époque il n'aurait pas été dans
la salle parce que grenoble était sous
la glace et même les gens de la
tour-du-pin je pense qu'il en était pas
très loin même les lyonnais il en était
pas très loin non plus la terre était
gelé en permanence à marseille et en
france vous aviez l'écosystème que vous
avez aujourd'hui dans le nord de la
sibérie avec juste juste 5 degrés de
moins sur la moyenne planétaire juste
saint gobain de moi sur le ring
planétaire je vous rappelle encore une
fois qu'une moyenne c'est une
construction intellectuelle que vous
êtes incapables et moi aussi d'approcher
avec vos sens avec vos sens vous êtes
capable d'approcher les conditions
instantanée et locales la moyenne sa
demande d'utiliser les messieurs gros
gros je sais jamais votre cervelle et
c'est quelque chose qui est une
construction intellectuelle
personne ne voit une moyenne devant sa
porte absolument personne
c'est une construction intellectuelle
1 et j'en reviens à ce que je vous
disais en introduction de secours la
confusion entre la météo et climat
c'est justement la confusion qui fait
que l'on se dit bois 5 degrés différents
sur la moyenne entretenir glaciaire est
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que c'est que 5
devrait on s'en fout comme disait un
homme politique que je ne citerai pas
ans achètera un maillot de bain et que
le problème sera réglé
non non non non c'est pas ça 5 degrés
sur la même planète terre c'est un
bouleversement absolument massif
deuxième exemple c'est calotte qui avait
considérablement grossi sur le nord du
canada et sur l'europe lequel contenait
et de l'eau qu'elle avait prélevé dans
l'océan vous avez une quantité d'eau qui
est donnée à la surface de la planète
donc si l'eau et dans les calottes elle
est plus dans l'océan
et comme le séance et des groupes
baignoire et bien le niveau de l'océan
avait baissé de plus de 100 m ce qui
veut dire que la manche par exemple
avait été transformée en un fleuve on
passait quasiment à pied sec de la
france à l'angleterre alors pour le
tournoi des six nations c'est plus
facile mais vous concevez bien que pour
aller pêcher des poissons dans ma manche
ça changeait un peu la question j'ai pas
mangé
c'est évidemment un changement
absolument massif vous aviez également
un changement de la pluviométrie qui
était absolument massif
les précipitations en france à cette
époque là étaient probables andyvie de
moitié par rapport à ce qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui
et enfin vous aviez des variations
régionales de température qui n'était
évidemment pas du tout homogène et
c'était pas une nouveauté cité 5 degrés
partout et tout le temps en france la
température moyenne était probalement
plus bas' 10 à 15 degrés par rapport à
ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
donc vous n'avez absolument pas dans ce
genre de contexte une répercussion
homogène de la variation de la moyenne
partout et tout le temps
la transition de la photo si l'on peut
dire de l'image de gauche à l'image de
droite est quelque chose qui habite dix
mille ans ce qui veut dire qu'une
transition de même amplitude qui se
passerait en un siècle
c'est quelque chose qui va 100 fois plus
vite alors la vitesse de l'évolution en
fait évidemment tout le danger
je vais prendre un autre exemple vous
avez deux manières de décélérer 200
km/heure à 0 km heure la première
manière c'est d'appuyer sur une [ __ ]
de frein ça vous prend 10 secondes
vous êtes vivant la deuxième manière
c'est rentré dans un mur ça vous prend
une milliseconde
vous n'êtes pas dans le même état et
bien c'est très exactement le même
parallèle qui s'applique la la vitesse
de la transition va si c'est bien
quelques degrés en un siècle comprend
très largement excédé les capacités de
réponse de l'humanité et donc tout ça se
terminera dans la barbarie
c'est très exactement ça qui va se
passer parce que les déplacements de
ressources et les déplacements de
d'endroits favorables seront trop rapide
pour que le système soit capable de se
gérer dans la joie et la bonne humeur et
en plus ça va arriver à des échelles de
temps qu'ils sont conjugueront avec ce
dont je vous ai parlé la dernière fois
sur l'énergie alors qu'est ce que on va
avoir comme conséquence eh bien je
dirais que ça ça va beaucoup nous
occuper la prochaine fois on va avoir un
impact sur les écosystèmes les
écosystèmes installé à l'évidence ne
sont pas les mêmes selon l'endroit où
vous vous trouvez
vous pouvez constater comme moi que les
échos soit que le climat qui permet à
des filles et de barbarie de pousser
c'est pas exactement le même que le
climat qui permet à des 50 pouces et
donc si vous déplacer rapidement les
zones climatiques actuelles un certain
nombre d'organismes qui sont adaptées au
climat actuel et qui n'ont pas les
moyens de migrer rapidement bas ils vont
cesser d'être adapté et donc ils vont
mourir c'est en partie alors je vais
vous dire un exemple les arbres les
arbres ont une vitesse de migration qui
pour certains d'entre eux est lente
prenez un chêne un chêne ça une maturité
sexuelle 40 ou 50 ans je sais plus enfin
beaucoup plus vieux vous et puis une
fois que ça a fait quelques blancs ça se
déplace pas à des centaines de
kilomètres 1
voilà donc les chaînes dans le dans un
monde dans lequel vous avez un
déplacement rapide des zones climatiques
favorables y en a une bonne partie qui
vont passer leur à gauche autres autre
exemple vous allez avoir des
compétitions entre espèces qui vont être
largement modifié alors ça je vous en
parlerai la prochaine fois dans les
compétitions entre espèces vous avez par
exemple l'apparition et la disparition
de plantes qui peuvent devenir
envahissantes ou qui au contraire se
font bouffer par des plantes
envahissantes
vous avez la compétition entre les
animaux et végétaux mais ça ou entre
micro organismes végétaux dont vous
pouvez avoir des apparitions de maladie
par exemple qui n'existait pas avant
et je vais vous donner un exemple que je
connais relativement bien qui est celui
de la viticulture
vous avez aujourd'hui l'apparition dans
un certain nombre de vignobles en france
de parasites qui était inconnu il ya dix
ou quinze ans parce que les conditions
climatiques sont devenus propice à
l'apparition du parasite en question bon
voilà on est typiquement dans les
déplacements d'espèces et ce qui va
probablement avoir le plus d'effet
significatif observable dans cette
histoire risque d'être le déplacement
des petites bêtes qui vont beaucoup plus
rapidement s'acclimater aux changements
que le déplacement des grosses bêtes
donc tout ce qui est maladies parasites
etc
il va probablement y avoir des tas de
choses auxquelles on ne s'attend pas
parce que c'est très difficile de
modéliser genre de chose il va y avoir
une augmentation du niveau de la mer
je vous expliquerai en détail la
prochaine fois ce qui contribue il va y
avoir un impact sur les courants marins
parce que la circulation atmosphérique à
grande échelle est quelque chose qui est
fondamentalement alimenté par les flux
énergétiques à grande échelle
et si ces flux énergétiques à grande
échelle change eh bien vous allez avoir
une modification de la circulation
océanique à grande échelle
et puis en plus vous allez avoir pour un
des courants qui est particulièrement
important dans le système aussi a dit
mondiale qui est la plongée des eaux
auprès du groenland un impact local qui
va être assez particulier et que je vous
expliquerai aussi la prochaine fois
et qui risque d'avoir une incidence sur
le climat planétaire
vous allez bien évidemment avoir une
modification de ce qu'on appelle les
phénomènes extrêmes alors cette
modification elle peut être de deux
types et on verra aussi ça la prochaine
fois il peut s'agir d'un déplacement de
moyenne où il peut s'agir d'un
déplacement des cartes hic le
déplacement d'écart type c'est ce qu'on
appelle la variabilité et c'est la
fréquence et l'amplitude avec laquelle
on s'écarte de la moyenne
un certain nombre de phénomènes pour
lesquels bien évidemment cette réponse
nous intéresse
et là je vais revenir à mon image du
modèle il est très difficile aujourd'hui
d'y répondre avec les outils dont on
dispose
parce que vous voyez que avec
aujourd'hui une maille qui est de
l'ordre de la centaine de kilomètres de
côtes et n'importe quel processus
extrême dont la taille caractéristique
est de l'ordre de la taille de la maille
un orage une tornade voir un ouragan
anurag ans a fait quelques centaines de
kilomètres de diamètre ça veut donc dire
que s'est matérialisée dans ce genre
d'outils numériques par quelques miles
seulement un est bien de cerner
l'évolution de ce genre de phénomène
avec quelque chose qui soit
enfin pour arriver à des conclusions qui
soit pas complètement fantaisistes c'est
ou impossibles ou très difficile en plus
il faut caractériser ce que vous savez
ce que c'est qu'un ouragan l'ordinateur
si vous lui dites pas ce que c'est qu'un
ouragan il sait pas il faut lui dire
alors avancé très précisément un truc
dans lequel la vitesse du vent des
pastels valeur pendant une durée
minimale de temps et que ça soit
cohérent sur un ensemble de bright star
qu'on dépasse assure une veille ici puis
ça sur une maille là il faut bien
évidemment que les malus haristoy côte à
côte
etc etc donc ça veut dire que vous avez
un bout de logiciels a rajouté dans
votre programme pour lui demander de
détecter très précisément ce genre de
trucs si vous lui demandez pas de
truc il le fera pas donc et encore une
fois pour des phénomènes qui sont sous
la paille
ce n'est même pas la peine de lui
demander puisque il n'est pas fait pour
ça donc quand vous avez et j'en reviens
à ce que je disais
l'orage de grêle un peu intense un orage
un peu intense la tornade un peu intense
et c est ce que c'est un effet du
réchauffement climatique
peut-être que oui peut-être que non par
contre avec les outils qu'ils sont
actuellement utilisés on ne peut pas
donner une réponse formelle aujourd'hui
c'est pas possible de donner de réponse
formelle
parce qu'encore une fois ils sont pas
faits pour ça par contre c'est
exactement pareil
vous voyez bien que si vous avez une
vague de chaleur qui ne concerne que
j'en sais rien moi la région qui va de
nice à montpellier et rien d'autre et
bien c'est toujours pareil avec ce genre
d'outil c'est très difficile de savoir
si oui ou non on a déjà affaire aux
premières manifestations d'un changement
climatique en cours
et il ya tout un monde entre dire c'est
cohérent avec des trucs qui devrait
arriver plus tard et c'est déjà les
effets du processus qu'on a qualifié
quand une fois on ne fait pas de
probabilité sur un événement unique
quelques problèmes
ça je vous en parlerai pas la prochaine
fois donc je vais vous en dire deux mots
tout de suite il se trouve que le ce
qu'on appelle le trou dans la couche
d'ozone qui est en fait la diminution
rapide de l'eau contenue dans la
stratosphère au dessus du pôle sud au
moment du printemps austral
donc c'est ça le trou dans la couche
d'ozone en fait c'est la diminution très
forte de l'ozone stratosphérique au
dessus de l'antarctique au moment du
printemps austral est quelque chose qui
nécessite des températures très basses
dans la stratosphère pendant l'hiver
austral pour pouvoir se produire
or le réchauffement climatique ne sera
réchauffement que près de la surface
en fait vous allez modifier le gradient
de température ce que j'ai essayé de
vous expliquer avec mon petit animations
tout à l'heure la vous à les confiner la
chaleur dans les basses couches de
l'atmosphère
mais ce faisant vous allez baisser la
quantité d'énergie disponible dans les
hautes couches de l'atmosphère
ça veut donc dire que le réchauffement
de la basse couche de l'atmosphère
s'accompagnera parfaitement logiquement
d'un refroidissement de la stratosphère
si vous refroidit c'est la stratosphère
de manière générique vous allez en
particulier la refroidir au dessus du
pôle sud pendant l'hiver austral et vous
allez donc favoriser toutes choses
égales par ailleurs les conditions dans
lesquelles la diminution très forte de
l'ozone peut se produire au moment du
printemps austral donc par une espèce
d'effet de billard à trois bandes
un peu compliqué il se trouve que le
réchauffement climatique toutes choses
égales par ailleurs favorisera la
persistance d'une diminution très forte
de l'ozone stratosphérique au dessus du
pôle sud au printemps et pourrait et
pourrait engendrer le même genre de
processus au dessus du pôle nord à
l'avenir alors au dessus du pôle sud qui
est plus dû traduire et on s'en fiche
parce qu'il ya trois manches au et de
chercheurs en cuir bi trop au dessus du
pôle nord c'est un peu moins vrai et
puis ces australiens qui arrête pas de
nous fiche la pâture rugby par contre en
ce qui concerne le pôle nord
il se trouve que les moyennes latitudes
de l'hémisphère nord sont un tout petit
peu plus peuplée que les moyennes
latitudes de l'hémisphère sud
donc si ce genre de processus commence à
se produire de manière récurrente au
pôle nord
malgré bien plus exactement que les
émissions de cfc est considérablement
baissé mais le stock accumulé est encore
là et bien sa produira un effet qui
vient évidemment nous intéressera plus
et pour cause il va également y avoir un
impact sur la santé humaine
donc ça aussi je vous en parlerai en
détail la prochaine fois cet impact va
concerner en gros le la possibilité de
déplacement des zones endémiques dans
lesquels un certain nombre de micro
organismes se porte bien il va également
y avoir un impact sur le ph de l'océan
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont un vieil
exemplaire de jules verne qui traîne à
la maison vous savez que dans les danses
et les romans co2 s'appelait l'acide
carbonique et il ya une très bonne
raison à ça c'est quand vous le mettez
dans l'eau ben ça vous a sidi philo ça
vous fait h plus d'un côté et h 03 - de
l'autre et h+ vous devriez normalement
vous rappeler de ce que ça signifie donc
on en parlera là aussi la prochaine fois
mais vous avez de toute façon vous allez
avoir une carte de ph dans l'océan et on
verra ce que ça signifie il va y avoir
des risques géopolitiques
parce que quand vous secouer un grand
coup le cocotier à un moment ou à un
autre il ya des gens qui trouvent pas ça
agréable
donc c'est évident qu'il va y avoir des
risques géopolitiques y en a déjà pas à
cause du changement climatique mais la
compétition pour l'accès aux ressources
engendre déjà des guerres des conflits
des émeutes etc
un certain nombre de gens ont expliqué
que ce qui s'était passé au rwanda est
quelque chose qui fondamentalement
trouve sa cause dans l'insuffisance de
terres agricoles
peut-être que c'est vrai peut-être que
c'est faux en tout cas ça y'a sûrement
contribué un certain nombre de conflits
que vous avez aujourd'hui en afrique
sont déjà des conflits pour des zones de
subsistance
donc il est absolument évident que
l'évolution nous avons mise en route
si ça a conduit à une redistribution
rapide des cartes l'histoire ne se
refait pas et jean ce qu'apprend dessus
qu'est ce qu'on a toujours fait jusqu'à
maintenant il n'y a pas de raison que ça
se passe autrement à l'avenir
retenez surtout cette dernière phase
avant que je me lâche
vous êtes très bien placé normalement
dans l'école dans laquelle vous êtes
pour savoir que quand vous faites une
expérience sur un système complexe pour
une pour la première fois il va se
passer tout sauf ce que vous aviez
imaginé
donc il est absolument évident que de
faire un inventaire précis exhaustif et
quantifier les risques n'a aucun sens
ce libyen aucun sens en ce qui concerne
cette affaire on peut les imaginer
on peut les qualifier on peut
éventuellement à la grosse louche
essayer de les hiérarchiser encore que
dès qu'on fait cet exercice
on commence à rentrer dans une zone
moins a toutes les chances d'être
ridicule dans 50 ans par contre il est
totalement impossible de rêver à la
situation idéale pour temps pour
l'action qui est d'être capable de
décrire très précisément à l'avance tous
les risques concours et donc de motiver
les gens pour qu' il puisse échapper
c'est parce qu'on sait très exactement à
quoi ressemble quelqu'un dans une chaise
roulante avec un lot en moins que l'on
peut éventuellement convaincre légende
pas fumer donc on n'a pas vu ça de près
c'est plus dur voilà c'est très
exactement pareil sauf que l'on n'a pas
le banc d'essai on n'a pas 352 planète
terre à laquelle aucun enfin auquel on
aurait pu infliger un changement
climatique avec quelques milliards
d'hommes dessus pour voir jusqu'où il
faut pas aller trop loin
on n'a pas ça donc on est obligé encore
une fois de d'essayer de se faire peur
avec un truc qu'on n'a jamais vus et
j'attire votre attention là dessus parce
que c'est une situation qui est
particulièrement inédite est difficile
dans la conduite des affaires qu'il
s'agisse des affaires personnelles ou
des affaires professionnelles
d'une certaine manière on est dans la
pire des situations où on doit avoir
peur d'un truc qui s'est jamais produit
et tout faire pour qu'il n'arrive pas
voilà vous rencontrerez des situations
plus simple dans ledit et là dessus je
vous dis à lundi prochain